اهلا بك معنا اليومنا اذا وضع انساني صعب
في تشاد بسبب الازمه والاشتباكات والحرب
في السودان
اثر هذه الازمه كيف تقيمين الوضع الانساني
ونحن نتحدث عن المساعدات الغذائيه
المساعدات الطبيه الاعداد التي لا يمكن
حصرها بسبب انعدام امكانيه الوصول الى
الجثث او حتى نقلها كيف تتعاملون مع هذا
الوضع الصعب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فلديهم تحدياتهم ومن الصعب جدا استيعاب
هذا العدد الكبير من الافراد في هذا الوقت
القصير طيب ما الخيارات امامكم يعني
الناس الذين خرجوا من الحرب في تشاد ام هل
تركزون في مساعدتكم على الداخل السوداني
ما المتاح امامكم
كلجنه دوليه للصليب الاحمر تركيزنا
الاساسي هو مساعده من هم ما زالوا في
السودان لان هذا هو تخويلنا مساعده
المتاثرين
لساعات المسلحه فالاولويه هي ايصال
المعدات الطبيه للمستشفيات
فالنظام الصحي على شفير الانهيار
ومرافق كثيره لا تعمل ونحن نعمل ايضا عن
كتب من ما شركائنا من حركتي اساليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر ونعمل مع الدول الجوار مع
جمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
واتحاد الصليب الاحمر لمساعدتهم في تقديم
جهودهم
للمتاثرين
الهلال الاحمر المصري
واساليب الاحمر في جنوب السودان ودول اخرى
كانت تحشد مواردها لمساعده من يعبرون
الحدود ما الصعوبات التي تواجهونها لايصال
هذه المساعدات خصوصا في ظل الخروقات التي
نشهدها للهدنه التي يعني لم تكمل يومين
وما زال هناك خروقات بالتالي ما هي تلك
الصعوبات التي تواجهونها هل انتم قادرون
على ايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين
تشالنج التحدي الاكبر هو بالطبع
الاقتتال المتواصل غير المتوقف الذي
شهدناه على مدى اكثر من خمسه اسابيع
والمفاوضات والاتفاقات التي تم التوصل
اليها بالطبع
هي خطوه ايجابيه كبيره
وتاكيد اثرت على الوضع
بالاقتتال الذي هدا بعض الشيء لكن للاسف
ما زال هناك كثير من التحديات متبقيه فنحن
ايضا ننظر الى
الاجرام والخروج عن القانون
بسبب
عمليات النهب والوضع للاسف ما زال متاججه
علينا مع ذلك ان نواصل عملنا وبذل كل
الجهود الممكنه لايصال المساعدات لمن
يحتاجونها فما من وقت
للهدر او الانتظار فالوضع الامني لن يصبح
مثاليا وبالتالي
قمنا بايصال
معدات جراحيه الى بورتودان وتم ايصالها
لوزاره الصحه
ووزاره الصحه بدورها قامت بايصال هذه
المعدات
الجراحيه للمستشفيات في خرطوم ونامل حقا
ان يبقى الوضع
مستقر وهادئ بما يكفي كي يواصل ايصال هذه
الماده ماذا عن وضع اللاجئين خارج السودان
يعني نتحدث عن تشاد مصر اثيوبيا جنوب
السودان يعني دول عده احتوت اللاجئين
والذين تمكنوا من الف رور من النهب
والسرقه والضرب والاغتصاب كيف هي احوالهم
هل المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه كافيه
لنجدتهم
[تصفيق]
كما ذكرت للتو فان اخذنا اي
في العالم
واستقبالها لهذا العدد
الكبير من
اللاجئين بوقت قصير فهذا تحدي كبير فهو
يضغط على الرعايه صحيه والمياه وكل
الموارد في الدوله حتى لو كانت دوله غنيه
ونحن نتحدث عن مناطق لديها
تحدياتها الامنيه على مدى سنوات طويله
وبالتالي غالبا المناطق التي يكون فيها
هناك من يناسب
المساعدات
الموارد المحليه ليست كبيره بما يكفي
وبالتالي الان عدد كبير ومهول من اللاجئين
يشكلوا بالضغط على المجتمعات المحليه في
الدول التي تستقبلهم كي تتمكن من
استيعابهم وتقديم الخدمات اللازمه نعم
هناك منظمات عديده بما فيها شركائنا
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر اللذين
يعملان لتلبيه الاحتياجات في هذا الوضع
لكن في ظل
حجم الاحتياجات الكبيره من الصعب حشدها
وتوفير الرد الكافي في هذا الوقت القصير